Vsauce Kevin here the folks behind the
new show timeless asked me to talk about
time travel and coincidentally I've just
finished building my time machine it's a
little rougher on the edges but if I can
get it to work I can conquer time why
would I want to do that while exploring
different periods in human history
allows us to experience firsthand the
aspects of humanity that have changed
and the ones that haven't but until I
get this thing working time machines are
a great device for storytelling because
time travel is something you already do
in your mind no really Chronos tisha is
the ability to remember the past and to
imagine the future as a guide for making
decisions in the present hypothesized by
experimental psychologist dr. endo
tulving as the only memory system with a
special relationship to time this mental
time travel process consists of two
parts the first is like watching a movie
in your head and includes the setting of
the event the actors involved and what
happened the second is the subjective
time it all takes place whether it's
past present or future being able to
travel through time mentally allows us
to learn from past events and project
how to react in the future this is
especially helpful in social situations
altering behavior based on how things
went in the past making friends and
making enemies human survival has
depended on mental time travel by
planting seeds for future harvests as
well as formally educating the young to
leave communities tomorrow or as tulving
puts it the kind of culture that homo
sapiens have created over the past forty
thousand years or so can be produced
only by individuals whose intelligence
includes conscious awareness of the
future in which they and their progeny
will continue to live and survive the
third little pig that built his house
of brick was really good at this but
mental time is subjective you can't
exactly tell someone to meet you
somewhere at the time you're thinking of
in your head
external timekeeping requires some form
of measurement like a girl disguised as
a lamp by a magic reindeer hiding from
the moon for most of human existence the
moon was a critical time keeper folklore
of the Chukchi of Northeast Siberia told
that after successfully eluding its
pursuit the girl captured the moon and
made it promise to stay in the sky and
mark time with its cycles the phases of
the Moon helped guide seasons and months
while the position of the Sun helped
chart the day sundials processed the
sun's movement by making a clock out of
shadows
which works well unless it's cloudy or
unless it's night time which is why we
started stealing water CLEP cider comes
from the ancient greek CLEP time meaning
steel and hydro meaning water water
clocks kept time by measuring the flow
of liquid between vessels in ancient
Persia a bowl with a hole in it was
slowly filled after being placed in
water in ancient Egypt a stone vessel
consistently dripped into a container
with markings that approximated the
hours the phrase don't muddy the waters
may originate from getting dirt in water
clocks and messing up their timing but
for thousands of years most people
didn't know what time it was the way we
do today and they didn't need to basic
circadian rhythm was enough no one
needed to know when it was exactly 7:17
p.m. hourly clocks served specific
purposes water clocks informed priests
went to perform daily rituals in Egypt
they were used as timers during legal
trials in Athens and they managed a
farmers water usage for irrigation in
Persia the impetus to develop mechanical
clocks came during the Middle Ages and
was largely astronomical measuring the
movements of the stars not everyone was
cuckoo for
clocks resistance to breaking down life
into tiny structured bits was documented
by Roman playwright plough dhis in 195
BC that gods confound the man who first
found out how to distinguish ours
confound them to who in this place set
up a sundial to cut and hack my days so
wretchedly into small portions flautist
what have hated alarm clocks Sun dials
and water clock simply split day and
night into twelve parts fixed length
hours and minutes were conceived for
celestial calculations by Greek
astronomers but mechanical clocks
featuring them weren't around until the
end of the sixteenth century
and public synchronized clock time
wasn't part of daily life until the 19th
century an era when the magic of myths
met the machinations of science the
Industrial Revolution brought with it a
new world of science technology
specialized labor discovery and machines
suddenly the curiosity of common people
was pointed at the possibilities
provided by science and they wanted to
read stories that allowed them to travel
to an imagined future of scientific
wonder describing the impact of science
on imagination
George Kari engleson wrote in 1874 the
appetite for the marvellous is a
universal one and from the earliest dawn
of literature until now there have
always been wonder stories eagerly read
of all men
ours is a scientific age however an age
of easy unbelief a question doubting
faithless age and we do not readily
accept even in the half-hearted
constructive way in which fiction must
be believed to be enjoyed anything not
borne out by hard visits fact a culture
and futuristic warp drive seeing land
conquered by train water conquered by
steamboat even hot-air balloons had in
1833 newspaper dreaming of time in
perspective when our atmosphere will be
traversed with as much facility as our
water these advancements made time
measurement more important in 1817 Welsh
social reformer Robert Owen campaigned
for
an eight-hour workday with the slogan
eight hours labor eight hours recreation
eight hours rest so if human life is
suddenly carved up by a clock why not
invent something that can conquer time
before clocks and machines flooded
civilization time travel tales like
memoirs of the 20th century written by
Samuel Madan in 1733 imagine life in a
different time but lacked a scientific
vehicle to navigate it today stories
from the time machine to timeless
continue to captivate and inspire but
the very first time machine was lost in
time seven years before HG Wells
legendary book there was the clock that
went backward written in 1881 it's the
first story that uses a device in this
case a grandfather clock to transport
humans through time the concept of time
machines required a convergence of
science imagination and the Sun a
newspaper called the Sun not the
fireball star Edward page Mitchell was
editor of the Sun a New York City
newspaper with the largest circulation
in the world at the time endlessly
creative Mitchell wrote the first
stories involving scientific
teleportation artificial intelligence
faster than light travel
freezing and reviving a life form a
peaceful alien surgically altering
personalities the Invisible Man and a
time machine the problem is the one
thing his revolutionary stories didn't
include was his name all but one of his
short stories were printed anonymously
at a time when there was no
international copyright law so stories
were easily stolen and reprinted the
only reason anyone knows of Mitchell
today is because science fiction
historian Sam Moskowitz spent three
years painstakingly poring over
microfilm and piecing together his
stories for 1973's the crystalman
stories by Edward page Mitchell
Moskowitz went back in time to
Dave Mitchell for the future but it
didn't work his book is out of print
hard to find and is also becoming
forgotten being forgotten is easy for a
person not looking for glory in 1916
Mitchell received an offer to leave the
Sun for the prestigious New York Times
and declined content with the
publication that allowed him freedom to
publish his stories when he retired from
working in the city that never sleeps he
moved to a secluded farm in Rhode Island
his isolated property spanned 40 miles
with Mitchell describing it as an
enclosure of treetops unbroken by human
habitation he not only cast aside modern
life he spurned modern conveniences like
electricity gas and central heating all
that was there was time all he brought
with him was his wife and his collection
of 6,000 books his love and his
imagination when Mitchell died following
a heart attack in January of 1927 a
two-page obituary and literary digest
the leading news magazine of the day
described him as hardly known even as a
name to the general public
Edward page Mitchell was the Invisible
Man
yet the waves of influence that emanate
from his creations continued to travel
through time and inspire us today proof
alone we have the ability to change the
future even if no one knows who we are
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
I want to thank timeless on NBC for
producing this video with me to check
out the trailer click right here for
more information check out the
description below I need to go figure
out what happened to my time machine so
yeah
[Music]
you